good morning John I'm back here again at
the Detroit Auto Show and this year has
been a little bit more exciting than
last year for me now everybody was kind
of saying that this year's Detroit Auto
Show is gonna be a lot less meaty and
that's not what I'm seeing like I'm
seeing lost glitz I'm seeing fewer girls
and slinky dresses trying to give me
steak kebabs what I'm seeing more of is
stuff I'm actually interested in like
green cards and so I'm going to you
really fast
because I really go to sleep I really
have to pee and my shoe is untied if I
stop and try and tie my shoe probably
gonna fall unconscious I'm just gonna go
we should probably start at Toyota
because obviously Toyota knows what's
going on and the green car front this is
the 2010 piece it's going to be the most
fuel-efficient car on the road when it
comes out it's actually bigger and more
powerful neill Prius but it's even more
efficient and it comes with an optional
solar roof talking to me but to some
people the Prius looks like a gas
guzzler and for those people we have the
Toyota f TeV which is like a smart car
but it's Toyota so it'll be cheaper than
the smart car also it will be entirely
powered by electricity if it ever exists
which hopefully Toyota will be making
this probably around 2012
oh my god
so Chevrolet's getting in on the micro
car action to that there is the beat and
they're gonna make a production version
of the beat called the spark then of
course we have my absolute favorite car
in the entire world chevrolet volt which
if you've paid any attention in the last
couple of years you know we'll go 40
miles on all of you power before the
onboard generator kicks in to recharge
the batteries and then it can go like
hundreds of miles so it's like an
electric car but it doesn't have the
limitations of an electric car and it's
also kind of pretty you like it this is
the new production version the last time
you guys saw it it was still a concept
version so this is what the car is
actually gonna look like when it gets on
dealer lots and if you want like a
regular car that you can get now that's
fuel-efficient there's the avail five
has a nice one
I don't know when they're gonna make
electric Camaros but when they do I'm on
the list John there's one question that
this Auto Show has made me really sort
of wonder sort of a general big
philosophy question this is why I
haven't peed yet I am running around the
show and I can't stop moving or else I'm
going to wet myself General Motors has
also created a new concept that's they
like the vault except it's a luxury
coupe instead of being a sedan and it is
hooked it's called the Cadillac
converged and I'm sure that it's ever
created way of my price range but isn't
it a nice to look at oh there's more oh
you know there's more running through
the Auto Show that's where the inside
would have been which is a great car not
just because it's fuel-efficient but
also because it's freakin cheap I think
it's gonna come in at eighteen five base
price we're just gonna open up a hybrid
segment to a whole different range of
people for example me so as long as
we're looking at cars that I could never
hope to be able to afford we might as
well look at the Tesla Roadster there's
an electric car that is not in my budget
hilly interest anything about this car
show though they're not only showing the
Lotus design shell they're also showing
what's it on the inside you can see is
kind of the world's like the most
powerful
most expensive go-kart and this is the
near production-ready plug-in hybrid
Fisker Karma
it's got solar panels on its roof just
like the new Prius so that is my round
before the 2009 Detroit Auto Show the
John I hope you like what you see if
you're looking for a car it looks like
the 2010 Prius is a good way to go a
Honda Insight if you want to save a
little bit of money and not as much gas
as the Prius and then if you wait not
too long the Chevrolet Volt will be
available with a huge subsidy from the
US government $7,500 up the ticket price
just for being a plug-in hybrid there's
a lot more hybrid options and there are
a lot of awesome things on the horizon
that is the 2009 Detroit Auto Show let's
do the spinny thing have I mentioned how
badly I have to pee